what else we have to do here man because
I don't know what's going on give a
little relationship advice maybe you
guys college it would help so many
people it's an Asian people death threat
because she told him to fake like he was
Christian to get with this girl I was
good advice to that kid with braces what
else you got
alright we got our boy this is Zack Zack
Kennedy I know he might be what up boys
is that coming to you live from Fisher's
Ville Virginia I don't I need some
relationship advice from you fellas
currently in a relationship with a girl
who's going to PA school and recently
she has asked me to help her with a
colonoscopy exam mm-hmm
that means she's gonna have to stick her
finger in my ass you know I I really
like her just cool you know but I just I
just don't know if I'm ready to get a
finger stuck in my ass like that like
just well just to be you know violating
the xposed I mean good livin but you
know he he didn't give me a warning now
that I have a warning I kind of don't
want to do it you gotta live anyways let
me know what you guys think if I should
or should not gangbang but stuff say
what up oh when she showed one of those
fingers to at the end with that he said
yeah said she's a little long in that
[ __ ] hand rope bro she got some
fingers on her I'm a little confused so
he's going in for a colonoscopy no his
girl is going to school like to be that
like yeah doctor mean let's just start
she wants to work it on him yes yeah mmm
it's not a sexual thing is it no she's
trying to learn now when I was a younger
man I was at this older lady who's a
weather girl and she just knuckle deep
Masshole man you have to get right to
get my mind right I wasn't ready for it
hey you put my legs up like a baby
like this so big oh dude she was like
this 60% chance of showers that's crazy
I want dude girl you you got someone
fire here oh this slip-and-slide now and
I you know it wasn't my thing but I
tried it because I got a live bro
oh yeah you gotta live a little you
don't know huh you don't know yeah go
for a hike or something you have to live
a little bit having somebody hold your
legs up in the air and get inside of
your butt now this was her thing
oh yeah well if you wanna go cheese
caramel own right I guess there's an
assist you know I'm saying she's Karl
Malone can't you be a woman in the story
I don't know any women I played in the
NBA yeah we'll just don't all right that
right all right I'm John Stockton cheese
Dwight Howard first of all I'm gonna go
with this for this guy dude and second
of all this [ __ ] guy bro he's
obviously letting his girl put her
finger in his butt a choice this dude
probably as a baby used to put a
pacifier in his butt dude this guy is so
ready to have a finger in his butt it's
insane he put on glasses so nobody would
see him he's on the [ __ ] witness
protection program bro
and he's about to get pointed out there
yeah dude likes but play I've seen this
but showed his lady at the end she's
sitting down relaxing he's wandering
around making a video at a Brewing
Company she just felt like this yeah two
fingers at the end she gave a peace sign
that's two fingers you nutcase
this lady's gonna hide all kinds of
Secrets to you but look at the look on
her face she's in charge suffice yeah
I'm not mad at her at all girl this is
about damn man I know but you know lucky
a nice young lady put fingers in your
ass what that's what's going on here
dude
she looked smart though you make your
money one day yeah you guys are
disgusting man
just cuz she puts their fingers in the
guy's but she's gonna be making money
you do it buddy oh I am alive to it
unfortunately right now look man this
guy's ready this dude is the frickin
super high this guy's taking all comers
into the old fricking finger holster
let's do Splash Mountain of but sets
dude this guy probably will have three
or four rings in his butt by the time
it's all over dude people will be losing
jewelry into this fella it's only up
from here my man yep good luck
[Music]